Pakistan now where former prime minister
Imran Khan is appearing in court in the
capital Islamabad he faces multiple
charges including corruption the Supreme
Court on Thursday ruled his arrest
earlier this week unlawful Imran Khan's
detention Sparks days of protests by his
supporters ahead of his court appearance
police imposed emergency orders Banning
public Gatherings let's get the latest
from Islamabad and speak to Al Jazeera
um
tell us about what's been happening
outside the court there in Islamabad and
inside
well first of all uh there's there's
unprecedented security around the court
also the place where Imran Khan was
being detained uh this is of course a
place which is a less than 10 five
minutes drive from that location right
now um Imran Khan is inside the
courtroom thousands of security forces
Personnel the police the paramilitary
forces have put cordons around the court
I hit lawyers are there and also uh we
are told that there's been a quite an
emotional crowd there especially lawyers
from the Pakistan tarike and stuff as
Imran Khan was brought into court he is
appearing to be confident he did not
answer any of the questions of the
journalists but reports are coming out
that he has complained that he was not
allowed to talk to his wife at the court
the Supreme Court had told the police
that he should be allowed to have
to be able to talk to his wife he also
said that he was apprehensive that he
may be arrested again when he leave the
court so right now the court is underway
there is a short break because of the
Friday prayers the court will resume and
then decide on this particular Al-Qaeda
trust case which of course the national
accountability Bureau says was why they
arrested him in the first place so
indeed dramatic scenes inside the courts
meanwhile his supporters who are trying
to come near the court on City nagar
Highway this is a major road leading
into Islamabad
have been stopped backgrounds have been
used many arrests have been made Senior
Party leadership has been arrested from
their homes including Shireen mazari Dr
Yasmin Rashid she was the former Health
Minister the former Minister for human
rights the foreign minister Mr Sharma
Qureshi has also been arrested a few
days ago and so there is a sweeping
operation going on by the authorities to
arrest their leaders wherever they are
able to find them okay thank you for the
updates Kamal Hyder live in Islamabad